i've answered hundreds of your medical
questions on this channel but i'm
getting burned down so i built a dr mike
robot forced it to watch every single
one of my videos and now it's artificial
intelligence thinks it can answer your
real medical questions so let's see how
it does huge thank you to simply safe
for sponsoring this video good question
why do i pass out at the site of blood
so it's a type of diabetes that you
really want to avoid unless it's
absolutely mandatory
what in the world dr mike robot i think
you've been drinking passing out the
sight of blood has nothing to do with
diabetes and you want to avoid it at all
costs not even when it's absolutely
necessary the reason you pass out the
side of blood it's almost like a
protection thing probably has something
to do with the vasovagal response or
neurocardiogenic syncope your body
actually has muscular control of the
arteries in your lower extremities
keeping them tight which maintains blood
pressure therefore maintaining
circulation of blood to your brain
bringing oxygen if something happens
like you're in shock or it gets really
hot or you stand up too fast sometimes
those arteries relax or don't adjust in
time as a result you don't have enough
blood pressure allowing blood to reach
the brain and you pass out are you good
at sewing after learning how to do
stitches i am good at everything
false answer dr mike i'm not good at
sewing and i'm just okay at doing
sutures like i can just do basic sutures
only dina is it true that drinking
breast milk is good for bodybuilding i
mean research has shown that it is 100
certain maybe not for everybody but for
me no not for me that was an anchorman
answer 60 of the time it works
every time
drinking breast milk is not good for
bodybuilding because babies aren't
bodybuilders
are babies bodybuilders because they're
kind of building their butt
i'm going to go ahead and say yes but
not for the type of bodybuilding you
thought i ate a lego is that bad i have
to say this is the worst thing i've ever
seen in my life is eating a lego the
worst thing i've seen in my life oh
definitely not you have no idea the
things i've seen in my life
you have no idea the things i've smelled
in my life the hospital is full of
smells sights sounds things that i wish
i could unhear unseen on snow azalea
what was the hardest part of med
q you school a lot of therapy what is
scq i need to google what this doctor
mike is is finding social communication
questionnaire i literally don't know
what that is but you do need a lot of
therapy so that is accurate jay tommy
could you overdose on helium like if
you're breathing it in to make a funny
voice yes absolutely if you overdosed on
helium you actually wouldn't die from it
it's technically kind of a status that
it doesn't really mean you're dead but
certainly a deadly thing
what in the world did i just read first
of all yes you could absolutely die from
over inhaling helium when you just
inhale so much helium that you're not
breathing oxygen yes you can die i
recently started trying to fall asleep
with a fan on to keep cool i noticed
after a few minutes of the fan hitting
my face though i start to develop
headaches is it possible to get a
headache from a fan yes and the most
common locations for headaches in the
anterior cingular cortex or the a-c-c
either this dr mike robot knows a lot
more than me or just completely making
stuff up this whole acc singular cortex
thing no idea what i can't answer you is
that you can get a headache from a fan
blowing on you because what a fan does
it causes direct cooling of an area
which can then decrease circulation to
that area especially if you have a
muscle thereby creating a tension
headache can i buy your dog no you can't
you can buy a used dog what is a used
dog no you can't buy bear i love bear
this gentleman wants to buy you do you
want him to buy you be honest
yeah i didn't think so either is there
any benefit to using natural deodorant
for deodorant that has aluminum in it i
love deodorant
it really does smell great but i've
never tried it on deodorant should only
contain essential oils and deodorant
should contain no added fragrances to
help your body smell properly
well i don't know what i just read but
deodorant should absolutely be used if
you want to smell normally the way
deodorant works is one of two ways you
either have antiperspirant that
essentially clogs the pores in your
armpits thereby decreasing the amount of
sweat that's released there by
decreasing the amount of bacteria that
eats it and then releases a foul smell
or you get a fragranced one that has
alcohol in it that kills the bacteria
and replaces their smell with the
fragrance
clearly this new technology isn't so
great at giving medical advice but
thanks to simply safe there is some
great technology that can protect you
and the things you care about simply
safe is having their best deals of the
year just before the holidays offering
50 or more off their award-winning home
security i actually got my dad to simply
save home security system which will not
only protect him and his home but also
our girl roxy who isn't as fierce at
guard dog as she used to be and the
coolest part is this wireless outdoor
security camera that comes with two-way
audio allowing you to speak to someone
at the front door setup is easy all the
equipment is reliable and it even comes
with a super convenient app so you can
check in on your home while you're away
save 50 or more on your simply safe
security system during your biggest sale
of the year visit simplysafe.com dr mike
to learn more remember dr mike is
spelled out all right let's get back and
see if this robot learned anything i've
heard that if you're having trouble
falling asleep you should close your
eyes and then move your eyeballs in a
circular motion what you're doing is
very dangerous do not let your eyes
close during these motions that could
potentially open up the blood pool and
cause you to bleed out
oh my god it's like cabin fever all over
again no you'll not bleed out from
moving your eyes in this fashion that's
a form of distraction you're essentially
giving your body something to do and
concentrate on at which point you'll get
bored and fall asleep so if that works
for you cool i like deep breathing
techniques like having an inhale of 4
seconds an exhale of 8 seconds is it
true that putting a wet cloth on your
forehead brings down a fever yes that's
great but it's not the only way another
thing you can do is to take some
acetaminophen and a sort of
antihistamine package and put that on
your skin it actually stops the fever oh
my god it started off so good and then
it just fell apart does putting a wet
cloth on your forehead bring down a
fever minimally
minuscule especially if you're really
sick your body's gonna keep that body
temperature up now if you do take
acetaminophen or any antipyretic
medication that lowers a fever it will
go down okay i know some people don't
believe in spirits but when your ears
ring it could be a spirit trying to
communicate but it is probably a medical
thing right i'm interested in this one
the phenomenon is actually a medical
condition that is essentially a disorder
of the heart specifically the left
ventricle this is the part of the heart
that actually has a voice to the heart
it receives the sound of the heart this
is the worst robot what you're
describing here sounds like tinnitus and
that is ringing in the ears and it can
be caused by several uh issues uh one of
them being sensor neural hearing loss so
there's a lot of different issues with
tinnitus there is a rare condition to
give this dr mike robot credit where you
could actually hear your own body sounds
including your own heartbeat so there is
some truth that you can hear your own
body's
processes in your own ears sunscreen
blocks the uv rays from the sun that are
damaging the skin the sunscreen also
block vitamin d and other positive
effects of the sun yes sunscreen is
important but it only lasts a few
minutes before that you should be in the
shade some studies even show that the
entire daily value of the sunscreen
consumed by americans is less than one
ounce so please use it responsibly what
is going on this is so weird sunscreen
lasts a couple hours not a few minutes
so fact check on that you should be in
the shade that's true the daily value of
sunscreen consumed i don't even know
there was a daily value i don't think
there is one while sunblock does negate
some of the positive effects of the sun
like the vitamin d it does still allow
your eyes to see the sun which allows
the sun to set your circadian rhythm how
do you prevent acne scars how do you
remove acne scarring you already have
pains beans just beans first don't pick
at your acne the more you pick the more
likely you are to get a scar also
treating the acne meaning going to see a
doctor a dermatologist to figuring out
the reason behind your acne could go a
long way to preventing scarring tal how
should patients go about finding a new
primary care doctor ask for a list from
our insurance company and play darts
insurance companies will have a list of
providers that they can choose from also
i love darts
maybe one of the most accurate ones
although i don't really love darts but
that's a funny answer there is a list of
providers that insurance companies have
you get the list and then you use the
web to try and verify if other people
have had good experiences there don't
just settle on the first one though
remember this is a long-term commitment
much like a marriage is it possible i'm
damaging my eyes by staring at my iphone
all day yes you can actually sky up your
eyes just look at it
what a stye in your eye has nothing to
do with staring at your iphone all day
like parents love bringing their kids in
and trying to use me to spread
misinformation to their children acting
like whatever their problem is is caused
by looking at a screen it's not always
the iphone that's our fault sometimes
it's serious things so don't just always
reflexively blame the iphone hey dr mike
i've been wondering this for a while now
but how do you know if i need to get my
toenails
if it's very removed like milk tons of
light tis you might need a foam
consultation if it's very inflammatory
like polycythemia it could be a genetic
problem milk tonsillitis isn't a thing
polycythemia is a conditioned
polycythemia vera where you have excess
production of red blood cells the
decision to remove tonsils happens a how
often you get strep infections b
lifestyle issues that can come about as
a result of inflamed tonsils and see a
conversation between a doctor and their
patient caitlin's world every time i
bend down or move my knees most of the
time they crack is this okay or should i
get it checked out by a doctor your
knees should be sagging at least
slightly during the day i would add that
your hips should be sagging at least
slightly as well possibly more so to
keep your hips a little more secure
okay maybe the only thing this robot
could be saying is that when you're
taking a step you should be bending at
the knees and the hips in order to
absorb shock i'm obviously reaching
there my knees crack all the time it's
no big deal for me but that being said
there are certain conditions like a tear
of the meniscus which can cause locking
and cracking sensations of the knee so
it really depends on what other symptoms
are present all these things are really
important to check and evaluate using
special tests with the art of the
physical exam
i challenged brad mondo to pick my
outfits and the results were not so
great but really interesting to watch
click here to check that out and huge
thanks again to simply safe for
sponsoring this video as always
[Music]